Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do: Dr. Bright can not give SCP-082 song requests!
SCP-082 loves to sing.
If there's anything he loves more than lying
and feasting on human flesh, it's busting
out a cheerful little tune from time to time.
However, as Dr. Bright has shown that he cannot
be respectful of SCP-082's tastes, or the
comfort of those working around him, he is
not permitted to request any songs from SCP-082.
Fernand was recently reduced to tears when
his rendition of a classic Italian aria was
interrupted by Dr. Bright's repeated cries
of "Do Free Bird!" and he also expressed discomfort
when Dr. Bright told him to perform "Like
a Virgin."
He should know by now that Fernand only likes
to sing one Madonna song, and it's "Vogue."